je m'appelle et à jacques boutet et je
suis en cinquième à les jeunes élèves
impliqués dans plusieurs comités dont
l'espagne
je sais pas c'est l'équipe de basketball
de mon école j'adore j'adore le ski et
la notation je suis une jeune fille qui
elle veut aussi rendre service aux
autres je vais vous parler du plan
funeste city à votre barre et des
conséquences qui se plaint à suréquiper
bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
du plach green est ici et des effets
qu'ils assurent la cuvée en 2009 lors de
l'élection du maire robertson vancouver
s'est donné comme but de devenir la
ville la vertement d'ici 2020 le plan
vélo city et le plan que va pouvoir a
adapté pour réaliser ce rêve je vais
aussi le pari du but de ce beau projet
comment ils ont fait et le québec dans
tout ça j'ai juste se parler du plat
bullet city car à la suite de reportages
ma curiosité a été piquée quand je
trouve important la propreté de notre
planète je trouve que le québec devait
faire plus d'efforts pour être plus vite
alors vancouver veut devenir la ville la
plus verte au monde d'ici 2020 en ce
moment ils sont premiers en amérique du
nord et 4e au mans les trois premières
places sont occupées par copenhague au
danemark
malmo en suède heredia les hameçons
le canada à lui est en 12e position dans
le classement des pays mais comment ils
ont fait pour se rendre en 4e pousse le
plan contenait disciples je vais vous en
parlez de 3 la première les moyens de
transport pour le vélo et la marche
plusieurs pistes cyclables ainsi que des
parcs ont été aménagés les autobus à
essence ont été délaissées all the bus à
électricité plusieurs automobiles
électriques ont aussi été acheté plus de
200 bornes d'électricité ont été
installés il paraît même qu il en
manquerait aussi la troisième ligne de
métro sera inaugurée cpt
l'aimant deuxième point les fruits et
les légumes mais pourquoi les fruits et
légumes salanque un rapport est bien
par exemple si vous achetez un aliment
épicerie comme une carotte
celle ci peut vu leur valeur par exemple
des états unis pour faire le voyage
elle a utilisé un moyen de transport par
exemple camions et celui-ci est souvent
polluants ce qui fait les gaz à effet de
serre ce que vous pouvez faire pour
diminuer vos exportations sont faire un
jardin communautaire qui est un jardin
qu'enfin avec notre personne ou bien il
fait que nous devions sens vous pouvez
aussi une ferme urbaine qui était bien à
la ville pour tous cas la campagne pour
diminuer vos déchets vous pouvez le
faire aussi je compose je vous êtes allé
taper le sml des sur internet afin de
faire du compost à vancouver ce monde en
procédant mon troisième près les
panneaux solaires les panneaux solaires
est une bonne façon de renouveler
l'énergie par exemple le tellure gordon
allemand le telus corp d'elles est une
nouvelle tour avant un combat
celle ci imposait en possède plus de 300
vous pouvez les admirer sur son toit
mais nous bien sûr le québec doit faire
plus d'efforts mais comment s'y prend
bien sûr on vous dit aujourd'hui je
cherchais le tout électrique ou mais je
pense qu'on pose ça fait ça peut aller
un peu moins vite que vous pensez alors
pouvait faire du recyclage mais pas
juste recycler le plastique les métaux
le papier et le carton
si vous ne le saviez pas vous pouvez
aussi receler d'autres choses comme vous
cellulaire et pire qu'ils ne
fonctionnent plus dans cette banque nous
avons une semblable au secrétariat vous
pouvez un souci de lait des vêtements à
décrypter pour les équipements sportifs
qui ne vous font plus ainsi que vous
jouez qui ne vous servent plus vous
pouvez les donner à des organisations
je trouve aussi que les écoles du québec
demain faire des efforts par exemple
phare du compost un jardin et
sensibiliser les élèves au recyclage
alors il n'y a que des avantages
le seul petit des avantages et de phares
efforts mais pour cela je peux compter
sur vous alors faisons que le vancouver
merci